Straight from her US tour, please welcome Aurora!
Welcome.
Welcome here!
Thanks!
Aurora, you've arrived
from the US now.
Yes.
Do you feel, when you're standing there
that you've got your dream job?
No.
You don't?
I think it's very rewarding there and then.
Because I get a nice
contact with real people.
And I get the opportunity to see people.
Which gives me hope for mankind.
It's very beautiful because they open up.
So I get to see the most beautiful part of people.
When I play for them.
It's very beautiful.
But afterwards I'm just ...
I'm finished.
I'm finished. Or
I feel like I'm doing what I'm supposed to do when I create music.
Then I feel like I know why I was born.
But not when I'm on stage.
Wow.
Awesome.
Then you just have to pass it on, but ...
Yes. It feels more like ...
When I'm in the studio creating music, I'm the mother, the father
and the child.
I'm everyone.
I'm the entire world. And God.
When I create and decide.
It's wonderful.
And it's a feeling I can't describe.
The feeling you have afterwards.
When you've made something that's yours.
Which no one can take away from you.
I love that more than anything on this earth.
But being on stage, I feel more like
maybe a
a tool.
Or something that it just passes through.
Just as if I had a hole in my head.
And it comes from somewhere else.
And goes out though the mouth, or the hands!
You're pretty concerned with how things
feel and what they sound like.
You're going to play for us later.
Yes!
And I was watching your sound check.
And I saw you walking around touching the edge of the stage.
And you touched some of the lights.
Yes.
I think it's ... I get ...
I really want to touch things.
I really want to touch the carpet here, now.
Feel free, go for it!
But. I'm really curious to know if things are warm.
You can watch something and you wonder:
Is it warm? Is it cold? Is it ..?
It's very pleasing to touch things.
And get to know ...
I often touch people without them knowing!
When I'm in a queue.
Or at the airport!
Just quickly.
On the jacket, or ...
I try not to, but it's difficult.
I mentioned earlier, you're not very fond of listening to music?
No.
Do you have any Eurovision favourite?
Uhmmm.
«Too Late For Love»!
The whole of Norway will be upset with you!
Last time we spoke together was in 2016.
That year was some sort of breakthrough year for you.
And a pretty chaotic year.
If I understand correctly.
Yes. I thought it was a difficult year.
Musically, I was a little ...
I hadn't learned that everything can't be completely perfect.
And I really struggled with that.
I've learned now! Now I can release music without becoming completely depressed.
But I couldn't do that then.
We said yes to too many things, we had over 200
performances.
In one year?
In one year.
And then ...
I was sick a lot of the time, and I lost my voice.
And I ended up in the hospital.
And I had to cancel my last three shows in the US, in December.
Because I had to remove my appendix.
And I didn't understand what that English word meant.
«We have to remove your appendix, miss.»
And I didn't understand!
You just knew that they were going to remove something, but you didn't know what?!
No, I didn't really understand what it meant in Norwegian!
And I called home.
And it was 4 a.m. at home.
My mom said: «It'll be okay, it's your appendix.»
«They will induce narcosis.»
And i was in a lot of pain, so I thought it was quite okay.
And they listened to my music while they were performing the surgery!
Wow!
Because they had to put a tube down my throat, right.
And I said: «I'm a singer, please be careful with my throat!»
She said: «Yes, of course!»
And she was very careful.
And they listened to my music while they were performing the surgery!
I was laying naked on the table.
And I was cut up.
Imagine, they've been inside me!
Simultaneously as they've been inside my soul!
I think it's fantastic to think about!
One has never thought about it like that.
But as you say it ...
It's very beautiful! It's very ...
I think organs are very beautiful.
As you will see in my next album.
What it looks like inside.
I very much love organs and think it's very nice.
I asked if I could bring it back home.
What?
The appendix!
To bring your appendix back home?
I wasn't allowed to.
It's probably illegal to take it over the continent.
That's fantastic!
You've worked very closely with
your family. And with your sisters, in particular.
And one thing was that they were worried about you, but
you have a sister named Viktoria.
Who is bipolar.
Yes.
What kind of support have you been able to give her?
Because then you've had another role, as a next of kin.
We are three sisters.
And we all have our vulnerabilities and strangenesses.
So when I was little, I didn't notice anything special about Viktoria.
Or, of course, special as in that she's fantastic, but ...
Nothing that was heavy in my life.
And we're very good for each other, and we've always had a very special bond.
And I think the most important thing I learned
as a human being and as a sister, and that I hope everyone else
close to someone with a mental disease can learn too, is that we ...
That when someone ...
When someone sends you anger and darkness or sorrow or tears, it's not ...
To know that it's not your fault.
Because that will make life hard, I think.
As long as you know it's not your fault
and it's not her fault. It's in a way a darkness
and a common enemy that both Viktoria and us as a family have together.
Because we know that this is something she struggles with inside her.
So I try to look at it like
it's something we stand together against. Even though she has to bear the brunt.
But she's very strong!
Both my sisters are very strong.
You're a person who carries sorrow for a long time.
Are you carrying a sorrow?
I'm carrying many sorrows.
Yes.
I've lost quite a lot of people.
And I carry a lot of the world's sorrows.
I think it's difficult to ... That may be why I think it's difficult to meet a lot of people, because ...
You can sense quickly in people if they're going through something.
Or if they ...
And there are insecurities. And people ... We can have such trouble putting words to our feelings.
And it can be so painful.
Everyone has something to struggle with.
And that's also something I've learned.
Especially from Viktoria.
And Miranda. And myself!
That we all have ...
Everyone should be a little excused in this life.
Because we people have a lot ...
It's difficult being a human being today, it's an extreme sport in itself!
But I do carry everything.
And that may be why music is so important right now.
Because it's a way to get it out.
Your production is huge.
You write a lot.
And it's being said that you've written a whole album
that will be published after your death.
It's very early to think about that, Aurora!
Yes!
I've thought a lot about death in my life.
I think about it a lot, but not in a bad way.
Not with fear.
But with a form of curiosity.
I think it's interesting that we're all going to die.
And that we manage to live without thinking about it constantly.
And that some of us can't handle it and that we ...
... love each other so much knowing that we may lose each other.
I think it's very beautiful.
It makes life, of course, very precious and all that.
I thought a lot about death when I was little.
I remember that when I got nice things for my birthday, I would get sad.
Because I thought: «But I'm going to die one day!»
«What will I do with this thing then?!»
«Then I can't be with this teddy bear or ...»
I started very early.
And that might be why I started to collect dead insects.
Because that was a way to
a way to handle that.
Because you keep it with you.
And it's a beautiful thing. And you can see that
the body still exists a little while longer.
Even thought the rest is moving on.
And I write a lot about death in my music as well.
But, yes, a life album!
I'm making that now. Little by little.
One song from every decade.
So I've got two songs now.
One from I was ten to twenty, and one ...
I've already written the song for this decade.
But I'm looking forward to ... It'll be a little more fun to die!
Because ...
Because there will be ...
I can say something to the world afterwards.
We hope that it will be at least a double album.
Yes.
And that it will take a long time to get to the publication of this record!
Yes!
Thank you so much for being here, we will get some more guests in.
Thank you!